hi everybody my name is nya and i'm the
black female engineer
and today we are going to be looking at
the resume
that got me my dream job as a
software engineer so let's get right
into it i have my
computer right in here and
let's do it so right off the bat
what we see here is my name
in big bold letters
this is very important because we want
to write off the batch
be able to say hey this is me don't
forget about me
and this is everything i've done so we
have
neither black female engineer and then
we have our
contact information right underneath
there so for me
that is my email my github and
my phone number now this is my resume
but it's not of course you know
that is not my actual email actual
github or actual phone number or actual
name
but let's roll with it for that little
portion
so right under that short info section
there
we have my education in each
section that i have within my resume so
we have the
education we have the relevant projects
additional experience and
extracurriculars
in each portion of these
everything within it is listed from
most recent to least recent
so if you see here without my education
is my coding bootcamp
first and then the university degree
that i received
some people would argue that it's
more important to put the most relevant
to least relevant but i
prefer it in this reverse
chronological order so we have coding
bootcamp
of course i actually put the name of the
coding bootcamp here but in this case i
did not
but i also accompanied it with a short
blurb
of the main goals and focus
of the coding bootcamp i don't imagine
this blurb
being different depending on the boot
camp you went
into it might be different depending on
the
program it was like let's say you did
cyber security or data science instead
of full stack engineering
but then right after that we have my
university degree
i went to cu boulder scope buffs and
as i've mentioned before in my previous
videos
i double majored in finance in the
county and so that was within the lead
school of business
and i put a section here
that would that would state
my gpa i did that because for me
i was very fresh out of college when i
was applying to these software
engineering roles
and so for me just you know university
brain
i put that but to me
even if you're just a few years out of
college to me
this can be very much done away with to
be completely honest
then what i think is one of the more
important sections of
my resume is this skills and passions
portion in the skills and passions
portion i really
just list out my personal
skills and passions and so really
making sure i'm noting what languages
and frameworks i'm proficient in
and also noting any other resources or
add-ons
such as git or postman these aren't
actual languages or frameworks
but there are things that many
developers utilize within
the development life cycle so decided to
put that in
as well then if we go down to
relevant projects this
was for me very important to make sure
it was
smacked back in the middle of the resume
because as you know i got into this
field through a boot camp and not
through university or
an actual major i was not a computer
science major and so
my experience isn't
with software engineering i don't have
software engineering internships or jobs
or anything like that and so
i really wanted relevant projects to be
the main focus
for the recruiter instead of focusing on
the experience i may not
have and so here i state the
three full stack applications i built
out
within the coding bootcamp that was i
can't breathe
piggy and mints i can't breathe i've
mentioned this
in my previous video of how to ensure
success after coding boot camp i'll link
it below
but i am very passionate about social
justice
and i in this case i decided to build an
app
that would really aid people
starting their social awareness journey
and that was i can't breathe
so with each of the projects i list
within the section
i follow it up immediately with the
languages and frameworks i used to build
it
and so in this case that was ruby on
rails postgresql
react and html and css and
i do this to one show them
that hey i'm not just saying i have
certain skills when
you know i really didn't build anything
with it
i really want to show hey i
listed these skills and passions up top
and look i've built
actual applications with those things
and so it's really to just
validate my earlier claims and so
then after that i list off
one what the app is so in this case it
was a
progressive web app providing
information about black lives matter
related cases such as elijah maclean
brianna taylor and lesser known stories
and it was deployed as of october 2020.
so
i in each of the projects i
list i like to give a rundown
of what it is one but then two
give some insight maybe into
some of the features it possesses or any
cool elements of the app and so for this
it was the fact that it was a
progressive web app below with piggy i
state that
it provides expense tracking and it also
has a
sleek and clean user interface and then
with mints
i state that it utilizes you know rest
apis
and crud methodology and really just all
those
buzzwords to really show the person
reading this hey
i know what these buzzwords are i know
what they mean
and not only do i know what they are but
i work with those things in my projects
and i'm proficient in such
verbiage and so i would highly advise
looking at the actual buzzwords
that the company or the application uses
when describing the job do they say they
want a front-end engineer that knows x y
and z do they say do they mention crud
do they mention
apis what whatever those
specifics are that they mention if that
is something
you are proficient in make sure you add
it to your resume
i'm sure we've all heard that thing of
oh tailor your resume for xyz
and to be honest it's true it's very
tiring and it can get just so so
just exhausting when you've been
applying to jobs day in and day out
and on top of it you need to customize
these
resumes it's very very just
a lot and so for me i recommend
adding those buzzwords that you may see
that you
hadn't previously had in your resume
adding them
up here in the skills and passions now
i'm not saying to lie
that is not what i'm saying don't just
copy and paste
words and you know vocabulary that
you've never even
heard of before that day don't do that
but
sometimes you don't realize you have a
desired skill
until someone says we want this skill
and then you're like oh
i have that and that's listed nowhere on
my resume so let me just make sure i add
that
that's what i mean so just keep an eye
on
the specific requirements and
qualifications that
the company you're applying for says
they want
then down here we have additional
experience so
in the additional experience that is
where i stated
my work background for me my work
background
was in financial and accounting firms so
that being bank of america merrill lynch
and
ernst young and so i added those
items because it's
the way i see it the things i have
learned through those positions many of
these things can be applied as a
software engineer
being diligent being detail-oriented
being motivated and driven those are
things that you want to show
to your employer that you are no matter
what position
you're in in both of these mentions of
my previous experience i like to start
off with a
more general description of
what i was expected to do day to day and
then i like to follow that
up with something that i did
that was unique to me something that
i did that wasn't asked of me a way i
went above and beyond a way that i was
different from maybe
the other people in my role because at
the end of the day yes it's great that
you know
did your job but it's even more great
seeing that you look for ways to
enhance the workplace and enhance your
duties
even when it's not asked of you so
that's what i decided to do here
and in each of
my notes of either projects or jobs
on the right hand side you can see here
that i
input the date of either when the
project was finished so
up here with my relevant projects
finished on september 2020
august july but then with experience i
like to say the duration
of my work so june 2019 to august 2019
june august 2018 because they were
internships so they were three months
long then finally
we have our last section for me that was
extracurricular activities i
y'all i just graduated college that's
what i call them
but i've seen many people add a final
section saying either
volunteering or hobbies and interests
um or anything like that and so for me
i've mentioned before very very
passionate about social justice issues
and so this last summer in june i was
the creator and organizer of a vigil
for george floyd brianna taylor about
aubry elijah mclean and the other people
who have lost their lives due to racial
injustice
and this was actually something that
was covered by 5280 magazine i
received support from elected officials
such as the attorney general
and it was actually covered by nine news
denver channel westward
5280 magazine so that's something i am
extremely proud of um for doing and it's
something i put here
because i want to share that yes i am an
engineer
and i will get the job done but as a
person
here i am and this is a great place to
put
really who you are as a person because
i mean at the end of the day when it's
seven eight nine pm
and y'all are stuck in the office
people just wanna like you you know what
i mean people want to know that they can
like have fun with you have
like joke around with you and it's you
don't want to make a bad time
worse and you don't want to hire
somebody that's going to make a bad time
worse
so you really want to let the company in
on who you are as a person
so put in the vigil and then i also put
in
that i was a member and mentor of the
device of the diverse scholars program
and a participant of the goldman sachs
undergraduate camp
and i would say that those last two
points are more school related
i'd say to really be creative in your
last portion of your resume
i heard a story once where this person
for their hub they had hobbies and
interest section instead of
extracurricular and for their hobbies
and interests they put
barbecuing and when the interviewer
asked them about this
yo they went in like they went
in on like the type of meat they like to
smoke and
the different spices they use and
the brands and like the heat and like
all i
i don't know much about barbecuing but i
was just like
wow and so were they so were the company
because
it was something so just like quirky and
different and
it was the fact that he had a it wasn't
that you know oh i like barbecue it was
like
the passion behind this affinity and
it was just very very hilarious to think
about so don't think
you need to be stuck in the bounds of
like oh it's a resume
and i need to be like no
like let the company get a sneak peek of
who you are
and then hopefully in the interview you
can let them in a little more and then
once you get the job
then you can let them in even more and
happier so
no just remember that you don't have to
be so like cut and dry
with these um
with these resumes so no y'all please
be kind because it's very scary you know
exposing yourself like this as a
previous business student you know that
our resumes is something we would keep
very close to our chest
like you cannot show this to anybody
because it's like your social security
number
it is like who i am in one page
so no please subscribe to grow this
community more and please press the like
button if you'd like
to see more content around
the job hunt process whether it be
interviewing or or more detailed videos
about
really what you put on your resume and
ways to make your resume even better and
stand out and things like that
and put in the comments what's something
that you would put
as your like hobbies and interests
something that would be
a little bit more on the quirky side or
just a little bit
different because i'm very interested to
know that i
i don't know i tend to see myself as
more boring in that regard
but no so thank you so much for watching
and later in the week i'll be
sharing some tips on how to actually
survive boot camp
itself less about the job hunt
afterwards
and securing a job afterwards and more
about
staying on track and getting through
that boot camp life
so stay tuned for that but
no see you all later bye